Jeffrey Clark thought someone was
banging on his garage door so I went
outside and
picked around the corner and saw him
standing there it turned out that
banging sound was gunfire officials say
an 18-year-old male high school student
who lived two houses down from Clark was
roaming the neighborhood randomly
shooting people with an AR style rifle
Clark says as soon as he saw the shooter
walk down the street he went outside to
help his neighbors two elderly people in
their vehicle dead and a woman on the
street laying Bleeding Out police say
the suspect fired more than 100 rounds
in 10 minutes before officers fatally
shot him the three people who died were
all traveling in their cars just three
pillars of our community and such a
tragedy